ja wenn wir ehrlich sind der Nerv mE
ganz schön all die Moralapostel wo
soziale medie zu all meinen und immer
mit dem moralische Zeigefinger rumlf
darf nicht Flüge Fleischessen sch gar
nicht du muss immer schön gendersproch
benutzen nervet ist die Moralapostel
eigentlich zurecht oder h vielleicht
einfach
[Musik]
recht heam heute reden wir über
Moralismus über sogenannte gutmönsche
und über der sogenannte Tugend Terror
und fragt wenn DF andere für
Handl kritisieren und vor allem wir aber
fr Barbara bist duis so lauft und alle
kritisieren
moralisch kan du mir jetzt sagen ob ich
so also W sag oder also bezüglich
moralische feh GLB ma ich das wirklich
nicht F irgendwie meist Situation was
abert natürlichis LT wenn man einfach
nur se wie mit Sache gesht und sich
schriff
also über ferie wo man so macht und dann
sage ich irgendwi so mega schön aber ich
tu mich so schwer ich w n Flügen denn
ich
mE kritisiert und das finde ich schade
ich finde es ist doch gut über ich w wie
andere mit dem schönatz du kritisierst
nicht und sagst du machst und irgendwie
du würdest ger aber du h so pfte ich
glaub andere kritisieren ich glaub das
ist wirklich nur am Platz wenn man
selber verletzt wird also mE mich
beleidigt so natürlich kritisiere ich
den die Moralapostel das wird ja immer
wieder gesag das Druck gehen das ist
moralischaden weiß nicht was darf jetzt
und so so ein blöd ganz ehrlich ich mit
de begriff ich meine ist so total
inostel tugterror
tugendzerei sehr gerne Phänomen reden du
mit soziale Media da geht große Problem
bin ich völlig
aber
insgesam in extrem freiheitlich
Gesellschaft so viel mehr wie früh
also der Vorwurf V Moralismus also es
gibt es Büch kurz ersen ist v Christian
Seidel und V Christian neuhuser mit dem
Titel was ist
Moralismus und das ganz schön sie l
Versuch klar machen was das ist
eigentlich der Vorwurf V Moralismus und
sag das ist übertrieb Überreaktion oder
überdenig V moralische ber also
für plöz alles moralisch also W ich mich
was ich morgen W under alles und alles
moralisch ne aber das ist interessant
das sag also fr was ist überdenig v
gstandsbereich von der Moral also wenn
sie quasi F moralbrill Lauf gagend und
alles hte Moral
Moral das ist fr der moralorie du ver
geht moralorie relativspruchsvoll sind
z konsequenttialismus oder wür sagen be
allem du machst musst du dir überle was
sind die bestmögliche Folge für die
größtez Beteiligte und dann h du
natürlich das Problem allem hast du dir
überle
mit Job W wo irgendwie me Mens DAV
profitiert ABS Konzert s die 30
die SP
genau
mus moralis darf das machen genau und
jetzt ist Idee Moralismus jetzt du wir
viel anspruchsvoll aber nur ein je nach
Moraltheorie ist Moral auch einfach
anspruchsvoll und es geht natürlich denk
ja also du Konzert du schon ein groß
Teil vermö Z spende ich w nicht sag D
richtig nur es gibt ein klassischen
Aufsatz der der 80er Jahr schon sehr alt
wird immer noch oft zitiert V der Susan
Wolf der heißt Moral sa moralische
Heilige und die seid wennt würde dann wä
das ein extrem verarm die langwiige
Stier um gabig und ich fin sie hätte dem
Punkt sie seid wenn du dir überle mit
welem BRF kann ich am meist l ren dann
wird ni mehr Tennisspieler wie der Roger
Feder es gab ke obere es g Diest
irgendwie mus das G immer für anders bra
und
pun das Z
mensensverstlichzu interessant also was
überhaupt überden von moralis das ist
Sel philosophisch Problem richtig Verst
das muss diskutieren und da wo die
Grenze sind was Privatsache ist oder was
die individuelle Freiheit ist und wo die
Grenz sind oder wo nicht ander Tangier
oder Freiheit ander das sind zwei
unterschiedliche Punk für mich oder
Moral immer stell wer das W der Punkt
mit Susan Wolf also wiewicht Moral und
thetik Z oder Ritual z.B das ist riesige
Frage Schachte oder Form von tiertötig
wo ges Religionen sehr wichtig ist d es
genauo macht DF moralisch argumentieren
oder nicht Humor z.ber das plözlich
Humor der mus mega aufpassen oder genau
aber mich wichtig sag das ist ein
Problem denn geht's Problem V sogenannte
kompetenzüberschrittig oder V der
überdig von der Kompetenz wer ist
eigentlich für was zuständig W ich dir
sage wie du oder so genau ja und jetzt
unterscheiden blue ich verzäh
irgendwie Problem und
so
und Fall ja so oder das so moralisieren
du m dich aber umgekehrt wenn du jetzt g
und du gehst W ich J verschl und sie brü
dann hoffe ich dass du also nicht ich
Mutter ist frag aber das ist die
Urteilskraft oder das Abwegen und Zier
und sch so dass mis der Vorwurf von
Moralismus die die tugendprotzer und die
und die die Dogmatiker oder die H
einfach so ihre prinzipie und
artikuliert sie immer und die das GP
nmen oder ja der Moralist ist also was
übertriebt mit der Moral er denkt alles
was sag und macht moralische Dimension
und triiebt das anderen unter nasse und
D das misch oder einige ganz schön Nerv
das LI irgendwie auf der Hand Bar es git
die die These dass man so das Moral
total hypermoralis Tugend Sittenwächter
und so wi warum halt ich nicht von der
Diagnose ich w sag ich halte n DAV die
soziale Media sind natürlich ein
brandbeschlünigerzglich dem Phänomen
grundsätzlich grundsätzlich finde ich
wirklich interessant scht übrigens
Neuhäuser diediagnose ist eigentlich
völlig vergangen vergang n Stück uel K
ST wenn man Tugend ernst nimmt
z ja du
mus
die und Trinken den vor dass man irend
zu moralistisch we dams gesellschaftlich
so viel feartikel und so viel Debatten
drüber ja ja aber ich GL Thema über das
handle Freiheit vom ander V Schrank dann
ist Freiheit geschrankt ja aber es ist
schon Frage du hast die soziale medie
erwähnt ich finde ist wirklich so die
tugendprotzerei das trifft s so oder zum
Teil einfach sag dass ich das auch noch
finde dass ich auch daz gehö und das die
ander des Teufels sind also die
polarisierig was macht und die spaltig
was macht die kassigkeit das H natürlich
mit Anonymität du sicher ja wir muss
Gesicht len muss noch nicht irgendwie
das Problem lösen und so sondern es ist
einfach so billig oder einfach so Meinig
gratismtig so fest überzugt von sich zum
Teil über politische Sache und ich finde
sie sind extrem kompliziert und komplex
ich glaub das kann man mega schön Label
mit dem Phänomen vom sogenannten Moral
grand standing ein Begriff vom wormke
und Toy hei die die hab das Buch sch zu
dem und die got drum dass sie sag es
geht zwei formme von Moral grand
standing ein ist genau das du
beschrieben h du möchtest quasi dir NOB
Anstrich du schrist mach selfie V V
nachtzog
und nachzog flü nur zum ze mal wie tol
ichtinktion abrz ander anders und zeig D
zu der Gruppe genau das ist Stichwort
signaling auf Englisch oder
tugendprotzerei auf deutch das finde ich
ich weiß es
nichteschmacklos blöd ich find all
dasich kannürag
moralisches Vorbild wenn du dich V
Nachzug Solidarität oder genau und das
Fin nicht ver muss Mo unstellen das ist
Form die zwe Form die got gar nicht gar
nicht gut das ist quasi morstanding Grün
der Dominanz das heißt du schst quasi
über was alles grusigemt du mach
undel zum Zwack bra du quasi aus im
soziale branger nur zum selber den
besser D ich find aber das Problem ist
so eine schenheiligkeit oder ein Doppel
Moral also l prediget Wasser aber wie
Trinket heimlich oder
klimaaktivist flü so und und
das wieso also jetzt noch
schheiligkeit zwei Phänomen
unterscheiden ein ich hat die ein
Schlaftee entwickelt und würde re machen
und sage ich sag euch ich habe immer
Schlafproblem mit dem Tee s ich der
trinke schlafe ich immer gut und dann
wdest du geseh dass ich heimlich dmikum
nehme das L Tabletten od genau dann wäre
ich schienheilig will ich nehme mich
selber als bewies für Wirksamkeit vom
Tee den ist das Gott nicht aber das mit
der klimaaktivist wo nach Bali flügt das
finde ich sch andere
Fall es doch so Sie dass ich z WD sagen
ich wünschte mirh es gab dies Verbot von
inlandflüg das K züber diskutieren
inlandfüg verbüte also kurzstreckfüg und
den sest du mich W ich nach Berlin Flüge
da kann ich dir doch sage aber
Arbeitgeber unterstützt das nicht
Arbeitgeber geht mir nicht Tag z
berlinzeich machen will irgendwie das
ist viel viel zit also kan do den nicht
sagen das ist inkonsistent son ich setze
mich h für
regelberch nicht vi Verstand wo du jetzt
bringst das bringen sie anderen niem die
was Auto braen auf dem Land Reg sch flog
machen oder weiß was die zum Teil gute
Gründe warum sie das nicht machen
und wenig Verständnis aber mich stört
ganze Diskurs ichfü nimmt denn so ein so
einen so einen
Person
die meist große soziale bew die meist
groß
sozialreformerecht V der Frau wo
irgendwn sind der Schwiz verdank sich
kampfestand sind für für Sache wo sber
viel Spiel gesetzt
und
sonder irendwie schwarzes sch und
da
schilig ich we
find ganze beweg diskrediti und stört m
ich wüns bevor man Moralismus brüllt
dass man mal genau seid was e Problem
ist man gemacht h ganz oft nimmt man
denn so Einzel BPEL me BPEL verzählt zum
die ganze bemüig und bewegige und sprü
diskreditieren und das ist nicht okay
und das passiert gerade bezüglich der
ganze Zivil unkuram Diskussion passiert
das extrem oder nimmt so eine spbpel se
wie sch heilig die halt sich selber
nicht mal und vergiss D da du
Moder Diskurs das ist unf das ist unf
jafunden Moralismus das hat viel mit der
sozial medie mit der Dynamik stattfind
das aber mit der sensibilisier für die
Frage wo nicht n schlecht ist s vor
allem gut Barbara wenn jetzt wie nicht
ma wie man nicht andere kritisieren
sondern was eiglich richtig ist was h du
für Rezept wenn wirklich direkt Unrecht
gescheht dann finde ich man bin sogar
wenig mutig oder wenn im Trum schlecht
behandelt wird dann wünsche ich mir e
dass ich GRI niem wird sagen das ist
moralistisch ich danke jetzt we weniger
Situation wo du irgendwie musri s
familienig sokel Tante Großmutter sind d
und dann GT umum EU und es geht um
fleischesse und das geht um flüg und
alle die
Themen
großartig persönlich B John Start m
er so viel lern wenn meine Freiheit
hochhaltet will entweder hab die andere
recht und ich l muss z falsch oder Sie
haben nicht recht und dann kann ich min
Argument n
wet falschen Argument also Heß auf du zu
du fr Aug trenst Mensch der
me mir genü wo massiv rassistisch ist
den W natürlich auch ungeduldig ehrlich
zum Glück geht so Familie nicht aber
klar das sind grenzbich es gibt ein
Aufsatz von der Monika Betzler Deutche
Philosophin wo mich wo ich sehr sehr gut
gefunden und der heißt open mindness die
got um Tugend von der
Aufgeschlossenheit und das sch mir der
richtige jatzch zulegen was beinhalt das
eigentlich und es git unterschiedliche
Punkt wo sie zammenfasst z kururz machen
Sachen sind ein aufeschlossenheit heißt
dass du dir immer bewusst Bister
vielleicht Motiv du nicht gesehst
vielleicht Nachbar so eine fette Kre und
ich frage mich für was brauch soes Auto
und reg mich auf und geseh nicht dass er
z Brüder hat mit der behinderig und der
jeder zweite Tag mit dem Rollstuhl um
Fahrt das ist das ist kürzeszu den
gehört zuu erkennen dass Sache komplex
sind ich merke z. immer beim wieauf wenn
man wieauft ist un rumstand bi aus Chile
die bessere Ökobilanz vielleicht wie
bius italiie und das ist doch
interessant das muss man irgendwie genau
überlegen ist einfach kompliziert und
dann dieig Vorurteil abbauen also nicht
einfach sofort W verzäht
irgendier sondern offenherzig mit der
Aufgeschlossenheit auf andere mit der
Idee ich selber
falsch le und vor allem nicht
argumentier das ist der berümte Backfire
Effekt oder das nützt einfach null das
ist kontraproduktiv die andere Person
verh sich den
Schitter l zu undis hab aber gich so
zwischen wie es macht und plözlich git
sag das ma ich jetzt auch we das finde
ich interessant die Strategie
Konfrontation oder mit soag ermut die
gibt ja auch beim Aktivismus zum Teil
oder wenn jetzt l was irgendwie
fleischess z. gibt extremere
Organisationen die rechtsorganisationen
wo Schock oder Schockbilder z.B und and
Tier und BL sä auf der Pack genau genau
und das macht natürlich ist verht seh
und Zielgruppen und und die andere was z
moderat Versuch Z WWF oder seit schon
weniger Fleisch ist besser oder ja das
stimmt aber mit gutem Vorbild V und und
me vi das ja dass sie sagen muss Mut
Geschichte verzähen Stück stimmt das ich
glaub ein Punkt ist no d nicht einig
sind das Tempo
alsoade WN Klimakrise redet oft fr
tempoag die die schöne wunderbare
Geschichte zuz sondern es muss schn
passier also der demokratische langsam
Prozess oder der disruptiv V
zivilenw
disruptivürich die ganz Debatte mit der
klimaaktivisten
klimakleber frag die Vers Stör
Aufmerksamkeit generier und Punkt vor
kurzem z.
kzern Aktivistin dirigantpult klappt da
gibtür noch bur und soer aber es
istmerksamkeit h aber es löst nürich
extrem viel Hass auf der andere s was
was h jetzt dur das Konzert W fahren
oder gichtig wen Problem BEK großem
Ausma alle betrifft extrem schwierig vor
Strategie zu fahren fahren
es ist das schwierig Thema was mich
irritiert ist sind zwei Sachen se ist f
jetzt klimakleber in Einätze mit
klimaaktivismus und das ist einfach ein
Gruppe wo das Mittel zum Zwack nimmt
viel viel andere im klimaaktivismus
macht genau das nicht das ist GB seine
und anderen ist was mich schon auch B
irritiert ist der Ort oder wenn manfüh
eine Aktion h B du mit dem wo man möcht
unterbinden also mant sich fest Straß
dann kann ich irgendwie einigermaßen
nachvzieh was das genau stört und wie
der Störeffekt laufen aber
Konzert W man denkt die L die W sich
vielleicht mal erhol V dem ganz Stress
dass man durend von de multiple Krise
redet und mal irgendwie auftank zum
nochher um so meh können im Kampf g
krisetzen h schrg sch wie falsche
ja aber kom natürlich noch med dann alle
ich glaub das muss man immer noch mit
genau und das gehört natürlich zum
zivilen unkurs dazu dass man irgendwie
möglich viel Aufmerksamkeit h finde
übrigens ein interessanter Moment Video
Dirigent ja offenbar GewSt mit abgemacht
sie genau und er geht derum und es h ja
nicht nur bur aber insgesamt find ich
schon ich w zwischen könen Konzert
genüen oder ein Film und gerade will s
eigentlich relativ viel Sorge was ges
problemeangt michzwishol und ich möglich
sie ja schwierige Diskussion als Fazit
könnt man vielleicht festhalten ohne
Kritik od andere G's wahrscheinlich auch
kein moralische Fortschritt aber beherze
ist elich immer der Satz der Ton macht
die Musik wie viel Moral das fürü sie
und wenn wird viel in Sache Moral Schre
Kommentar wenn er mE wüs zum Thema gibt
ein Stammtisch zum Thema cancel culture
und das Gespräch mit Autorin mitusanial